i have used bret's statement of we must
defeat the biden trump ticket
in telling others about unity 2020. i
think it's a very effective slogan
i do too defeat trump biden 2020.
why do you think why do you two think
reelecting donald trump would be a bad
idea
i know he's not very presidential but
bring but bringing industry and jobs to
the us and getting troops out of the
middle east
sounds good please elaborate and thank
you
um let's put it this way we have seen
the man's inability to
lead at moments when it is necessary
there are
things he has pointed towards yes
pulling people out of the middle east
is sensible if it can be done safely
certainly we've created
tremendous hazards for ourselves and
we've burned
an awful lot of treasure in the middle
east on adventures that did not work out
so it's not to say that every single
thing
points against the man but we need a
leader who can deal
with covet 19. trump botched this
badly people died in great numbers right
we need people
who are able to figure out how to listen
to experts and what to do about it and
how to deal with the fact that some of
the experts aren't trustworthy
this is just simply necessary so no he's
he's slid
over from uh being completely embedded
in the system
uh that has someone else's interests at
heart but which is completely informing
the president to saying i trust none of
them
and you know maybe the right president
actually needs to
from scratch figure out who it is that
they trust
and accept no one who was handed to him
or her because
um because that's what's been done
before but the idea that
there will be no one whom he comes
consults no one whom he trusts
with the possible exception of a couple
of people right in his immediate family
is clearly led to so many mistakes and
just a failure to govern yeah and we
have an economic crisis
we have a viral crisis
we have a unrest crisis and we
may be on the tipping point of an
environmental crisis
so we need somebody who is a careful
thinker
and who has the right leadership
qualities
written in at the bottom level of their
code and i'm sorry
he had the right qualities to beat one
of the two major parties that's a major
accomplishment but
he doesn't have the right temperament to
lead the nation at this point and
he's got to go
[Music]